now to ukraine where ukrainian forces
say they are gaining ground in a new
counter offensive against russia there's
heavy fighting right now in the area
around kirsten a crucial port city near
the black sea meanwhile there are fears
that europe's largest nuclear plant has
been damaged in the fighting a team of
international investigators is in
ukraine to assess the situation at the
facility which is in russian occupied
territory deborah patta has more from
keith
more than half a year of russian
occupation has turned the zaparisia
nuclear power plant into a military base
that runs along an explosive front line
with both sides trading accusations of
shelling in the area
keith blamed russia for hitting the
nearby village of nelgadar while russia
claims a ukrainian missile strike
punched this giant hole in a fuel depot
at the site
a chilling warning that the fighting
could cause a disastrous meltdown from
ukrainian presidential advisor sergey
leshenko it's international terrorism
nuclear terror is what russia is doing
in zapposia
this
nuclear power station is the biggest in
in europe and in case of catastrophe is
going to be six times more than in
chernobyl the un inspection is set to
start tomorrow but it comes amid an
intense battle to liberate occupied
hassan further south
emboldened by the steady supply of
western military aid ukraine is holding
nothing back
they're hitting us with everything
they've got tanks aviation artillery
shots this russian soldier
the much talked up counter-offensive has
intensified her son was the first major
city to fall in the early days of the
war for more than six months residents
say they've been living in fear under
their russian occupiers accusing them of
kidnap and torture
now this is the first time that atomic
energy inspectors will be investigating
a nuclear plant occupied during an
ongoing war they will assess damages at
the russian-controlled site as well as
evaluate security concerns and the
conditions under which ukrainian
technicians are working gail
all right deborah powder reporting from
ukraine we thank you